quanti credono a babbo natale
tutti gli altri in the box
questo mio figlio davide
il quinto dei miei figli cinque figli
tutti i miei lo giuro
almeno io pago quindi
a natale ci sono ha raccontato una
storia a casa di un nostro amico il papa
si è vestito da babbo natale
è una casa a due piani
scendendo le scale vestito da babbo
natale col sacco pieno di doni è
scivolato sulle scale ha picchiato alla
testa ed è svenuto a quel punto la mamma
aveva due scelte o rovinare
l'incantesimo delle esistenze babbo
natale o prendere il figlio mettere una
stanza soccorre il suo marito togli la
barba toglie il cappello
rinfrescarlo farlo ridestare a gennaio
il bambino torna a scuola e cosa
raccontava ai suoi compagni di classe
1 babbo natale esiste
2 e morto a casa mia
fantastico
qantas che l'hanno raccontata fantastico
perché babbo natale esiste
babbo natale muore e non è un problema
per noi non può morire non esiste se
esiste un po morire e casomai sapersi
morire e certamente non morire a casa
nostra
allora io voglio parlarvi di economia
0.0 e capirete perché sono partito con
questa storia io adoro andarmi a
studiare l'etimologia delle parole
economia arte di reggere amministrare
bene le cose della famiglia e dello
stato e qua c'è già una cosa
affascinantissima arte di reggere
amministrare bene le cose della famiglia
quindi una dimensione soggettiva
personale dello stato prima cosa che
riguarda tutti poi incuriosito sonata di
dare un significato alla parola arte
che se non ricordo male eh
ogni attività umana che porta forme
creative di espressione ogni attività
umana che porta a forme creative di
espressione quindi sintesi l'economia è
e arte l'arte è tutto e la vita la vita
per proprietà transitiva economia quindi
benvenuti voi che siete economisti e che
siete artisti
lo sapevate no in the box 2
tutt'oggi se ci pensate bene è
catalogata quello 0.0 parlando di
economia non esiste nulla allo 0.0 alta
esiste una matrice cosiddetto the matrix
economica evolution che mette allo 0.0
una condizione primitiva la comunità
gestiva il capitale era la natura e la
natura veniva gestita come bene dalla
comunità le piccole comunità 1.0
capitale al capitale umano inteso come
forza lavoro e coloro che lo gestivano
erano degli stati originariamente delle
gerarchie 2.0 il capitale era quello
industriale è stato fino a poco fa
quella industriale e chi gestiva tutto
questo era il mercato è iniziato ad
esserci un mix tra pubblico e privato
che poi è stato esasperato nell'economia
3.0 dove a gestire questo mix di
pubblico privato e l'oggetto è stata per
l'appunto alla tecnologia
tendenzialmente in questa scala si
dovrebbe arrivare un economia 4.0 del
capitale diventa un capitale culturale
condiviso creativo dove loughner non è
più la comunità non è più lo stato non
sono più le imprese ma è il mondo intero
perché siamo tutti interconnessi uno con
l'altro
tendenzialmente vivevano a domandarsi
cosa sarebbe il 5.0 6.0 in realtà però
se al momento molto particolare c'è un
momento dove tutto questo rischierebbe
di non sostenersi più perché il sistema
ancora fortemente concentrato
sull'aspetto ego e non su un aspetto
ecco quindi tendenzialmente la fase 4.0
potrebbe non arrivare
tant'è che come avete sentito raccontare
oggi come certamente saprete come
sentirete anche nei prossimi discorsi
stiamo andando una velocità incredibile
raggiungendo degli standard che erano
inimmaginabili figo fino a pochissimi
mesi fa di contro però al contempo ci
sono situazioni che non sono più
sostenibili situazioni come questa
situazione come questa situazione come
questa
e quindi noi dobbiamo assolutamente
farci una domanda gandhi diceva non è
importante la velocità qui vai è
importante la direzione
allora riflessione io sto anche con
gregoli pezzo anche notissimo
antropologo ecologo e psichiatra se
questo modello io contro il mondo è
l'indicazione del vostro rapporto con la
natura e possedete una tecnologia
avanzata allora la vostra possibilità di
sopravvivenza sarà pari a quella di una
palla di neve all'inferno dobbiamo farci
una domanda abbiamo io sono qui per i
miei figli in quella la mia famiglia se
non ci diamo tutti una regolata e non
diamo l'orientamento molto importante il
rischio è quello di non avere un destino
e di tornare una condizione 0.0 che una
condizione primitiva la proposta invece
un'altra è quella di provare a
ridestarsi per un istante ed esattamente
come einstein diceva quando c'è un
problema bisogna questo problema va
risolto a un livello di coscienza
maggiore del livello di dove il problema
si è prodotto e parlando di noi per
livello di coscienza si intende quindi
andare per un istante in profondità e
quindi provare più distante riguardarsi
dentro perché alla fine se noi siamo
stati l'origine di qualche problema noi
siamo l'unica possibile origine di
qualche soluzione e soprattutto c'è una
nuova consapevolezza che l'umanità sta
maturando grazie anche ad alcune
scoperte in natura scientifica
cito ad esempio la fisica quantistica e
il prendere consapevolezza che siamo
ormai tutti interconnessi con tutto non
solo perché con un click noi siamo in
contatto con altri 7 miliardi di esseri
viventi sul pianeta ma perché siamo
proprio energeticamente interconnessi
con tutto il passaggio alla 0.0 e
riprendere la consapevolezza che la mia
sorte dipende dalla tua sorte è che c'è
una sorte comune al di là della quale
non c'è più possibilità
se riuscissimo a superare il passaggio
tra il giusto e lo sbagliato il bene e
il male il bianco il nero e ri
considerarsi tutti parte di un insieme
sarebbe molto più facile passare da
condizioni tipo questa e torna
l'etimologia della parola arte di
amministrare bene le cose della famiglia
dello stato è sempre fino ad oggi stata
la storia dell'umanità scandita da
momenti dove famiglie avevano punti di
vista diversi stati avevano punti di
vista diversi se riusciamo a fare del
tutto questo un insieme e iniziare a
considerarci come una parte del tutto e
il tutto come espressione dell'uno trovo
che la soluzione sia molto molto
perseguibile uno dei mistici più
importanti dell'islam dice va ben oltre
l'idea di giusto e sbagliato
c'è un campo ti aspetterò la in quel
campo a mio parere c'è l'economia 0.0
signore noi abbiamo una vita ma siamo
tutti a tempo per quanto continua ad
inventare
comunque abbiamo un tempo entro il quale
ci viene chiesto di produrre un frutto
e questo frutto è lasciare un segno è un
segno e solo tutto ciò che veramente da
un contributo per l'insieme se pensava
la vita dei grandi uomini sono stati
tutti economisti artisti 0.0 martin
luther king ghandi madre teresa minimo
sforzo
una vita sacrificata massimo risultato
grandissimi valori che tutt'oggi vengono
perseguiti dalla comunità
e chiaro che sono pensa solo nella
dimensione soggettiva una sacrificato
tutto se stesso però sono persone che
hanno scandito pietre miliari della
nostra evoluzione quindi la proposta è
continuare a fare tutto ma provare a
riorientare un attimo provando ad andare
dentro per un istante è la più grande
forma di economia che l'uomo ha prodotto
finora a mio parere è l'arte non a caso
si parlava di arte quale ogni attività
umana sapete perché l'arte economia
l'arte produce in quasi tutti quelli che
la incontrano l'arte vera e l'arte vera
è quella che produce bellezza e questa
città né ricchissima tutti noi che
dovessimo
guardare questa chiesa questa cattedrale
avremmo tutti faremo tutti la stessa
esperienza tutti indipentemente la
orientamenti politici filosofici
religiosi guarderemo tutti in alto e
tutti noi di fronte a un'opera come
questa abbiamo proviamo un senso di
bellezza l'arte economia la bellezza
economia perché fa provare a tutti la
medesima esperienza quando l'arte
oggettiva e soprattutto rende anche
finanziariamente opere fatte secoli fa
ancora oggi da chi ha investito in
quegli artisti sono fonte di reddito
oggettivo e questo sarà l'aspetto
economico di natura finanziaria quello
più basico investire nel bello investire
nel sano investire nel utile e ciò che
fa la differenza
passare da ciò che è bene e ciò che è
utile per l'insieme come concezione è
quello che mi ha pure ci potrà salvare
dostoevskij diceva parlando di bellezza
la bellezza ci salverà
qual è la più grande forma di bellezza
esistente mio parere l'amore è parlare
di amore oggi sta diventando la cosa
così banale così scontata che non ne
parla nessuno ma economico tutti gli
esseri umani desiderano amare tutti gli
esseri umani desiderano essere amati è
l'unica moneta che viene data senza
desiderare nulla in cambio
è l'unica moneta che quando paghi sei
felice di aver pagato ed è l'unica
moneta che una volta utilizzata chi
ripagherà nella stessa quantità e in
assoluto l'atto economico di maggiore
efficacia che esista quando dai il
miracolo avviene e tu ricevi e qual è la
tua
all'origine di tutto questo proprio
dell'amore ciascuno di noi
tutto dovrebbe partire come economia 0.0
st dovesse sembrare banale alle tue
ranking tutto questo dovesse suonare
come ovvio facciamoci una domanda perché
uscendo là fuori in tv non si parla di
questo sui giornali non si parla di
questo sul web non si parla di questo
nei discorsi fra le persone in giro non
si parla di questo
così ovvio e banale che non ne parla
nessuno
l'essenza dell'atto economico per
eccellenza sei tu la vita economia
l'economia e arte la più alta forma
d'arte la bellezza la più la cosa più
bella in assoluto è l'amore l'essenza
dell'amore e ciascuno di noi grazie